Speaker 1: Thank you, hello everybody, nice to see you,
Speaker 1: it's always good to be together.
Speaker 1: So I wanted to talk today about what makes
Speaker 1: enlightenment actually possible, because
Speaker 1: it's a very mysterious process and I want
Speaker 1: to try to help to demystify how it all
Speaker 1: works.
Speaker 1: I can't ultimately demystify it, because
Speaker 1: how it works is ultimately a mystery to me,
Speaker 1: but I have come to understand a few things
Speaker 1: about it and I hope, today to help to
Speaker 1: demystify what we can actually do if we
Speaker 1: want to maintain enlightened awareness and
Speaker 1: cultivate the capacity to experience it on
Speaker 1: a regular basis.
Speaker 1: I think I can help in this area.
Speaker 1: So, in my understanding, there's basically
Speaker 1: two approaches to enlightenment.
Speaker 1: One is called the gradual path.
Speaker 1: The gradual path takes time and continuous
Speaker 1: practice and effort, and then there's the
Speaker 1: sudden path, which happens instantaneously
Speaker 1: and it's not something you need to work at.
Speaker 1: So there's what's called the path of sudden
Speaker 1: awakening versus the gradual path, which
Speaker 1: takes time.
Speaker 1: I became a seeker when I was 22, and I
Speaker 1: practiced Kriya Yoga, which is a form of
Speaker 1: Kundalini Yoga meditation, for several
Speaker 1: years very seriously, which is a gradual
Speaker 1: path of awakening, and I had many powerful
Speaker 1: experiences doing that.
Speaker 1: And then, like so many other people.
Speaker 1: I began to practice Vipassana meditation.
Speaker 1: I did many, many intensive, long
Speaker 1: Viposterous retreats, some for months on
Speaker 1: end, and that form of Buddhist meditation
Speaker 1: is definitely a gradual path, very gradual,
Speaker 1: and I learned a lot about the nature of my
Speaker 1: mind, the nature of mind.
Speaker 1: I learned a lot about taking the position
Speaker 1: of being the witness to all of our
Speaker 1: experience and I experienced many deep
Speaker 1: states of consciousness during those
Speaker 1: retreats.
Speaker 1: But I didn't find what I was looking for
Speaker 1: until I met my guru, the great HWL Punja,
Speaker 1: in 1986 in Lucknow and after sitting in
Speaker 1: front of him for about 10 minutes, I had a
Speaker 1: very powerful experience of awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: That happened very quickly.
Speaker 1: After sitting in front of in front of me
Speaker 1: for, as I said, a very short time, I had a
Speaker 1: mysterious and miraculous realization that
Speaker 1: I'd always at the deepest level level of
Speaker 1: consciousness, I'd always been free and
Speaker 1: that, as I understood it at the time,
Speaker 1: unenlightenment was only a thought.
Speaker 1: So my guru, hw Alpunja, was a teacher of
Speaker 1: instant enlightenment.
Speaker 1: He was not an advocate of the gradual path.
Speaker 1: He disdained any approach to the absolute
Speaker 1: or to enlightenment.
Speaker 1: That took time Because he said he was a
Speaker 1: disciple of Ramana Maharshi.
Speaker 1: Ramana Maharshi called ultimate or absolute
Speaker 1: reality, the self, capital, s-c-l-l.
Speaker 1: So he said, if the self exists beyond time,
Speaker 1: how could doing anything in time help you
Speaker 1: to get beyond time?
Speaker 1: So, in his approach, if you wanted to be
Speaker 1: free, if you wanted to attain enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, you needed to recognize that at
Speaker 1: the deepest level of your being it was
Speaker 1: already so.
Speaker 1: The deepest level of your being, it was
Speaker 1: It was always already so.
Speaker 1: Because, from the perspective of the path
Speaker 1: of Advaita Vedanta and the realization of
Speaker 1: non-duality that he was teaching, advaita
Speaker 1: Vedanta always points us directly to the
Speaker 1: nature of our own consciousness.
Speaker 1: Just look and pay attention to the nature
Speaker 1: of your own consciousness.
Speaker 1: See that consciousness, that your own
Speaker 1: subjective experience of interiority of
Speaker 1: consciousness is timeless and formless and
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless.
Speaker 1: Right now, consciousness, the awakening to
Speaker 1: consciousness, the recognition of
Speaker 1: consciousness, the discovery of
Speaker 1: consciousness, is what awakening to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness in the traditional
Speaker 1: sense is all about.
Speaker 1: When you discover your own consciousness,
Speaker 1: when you stumble upon your own
Speaker 1: consciousness, which most people miss.
Speaker 1: That's what enlightenment is and that's
Speaker 1: either a temporary realization or it can
Speaker 1: become a sustained realization.
Speaker 1: So consciousness, which is the source of
Speaker 1: the subjective sense of I-ness, it's the
Speaker 1: source of the I-sense.
Speaker 1: Your consciousness and my consciousness is
Speaker 1: the source of who I am and the source of
Speaker 1: who you are.
Speaker 1: Most of us don't know that.
Speaker 1: Most of us believe that who we are is a
Speaker 1: separate self-sense that had a beginning in
Speaker 1: time.
Speaker 1: But when we awaken to consciousness itself,
Speaker 1: when we awaken to consciousness directly,
Speaker 1: we realize that the source of the mystery
Speaker 1: of interiority or subjectivity is infinite
Speaker 1: and abides beyond time.
Speaker 1: Because it abides beyond time, it abides
Speaker 1: beyond the mind.
Speaker 1: So when this discovery is made, this is the
Speaker 1: beginning of the awakening to enlightenment,
Speaker 1: to enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: We can work at this in the meditative
Speaker 1: process or in the practice of meditation.
Speaker 1: We can work to try and transcend the mind
Speaker 1: using meditative techniques.
Speaker 1: And this can and does and will, if we stick
Speaker 1: with it long enough and if we are serious
Speaker 1: enough about it, will give us glimpses into
Speaker 1: what lays beyond our own mind.
Speaker 1: In the situation with my own teacher,
Speaker 1: because his awakening was so powerful, his
Speaker 1: enlightenment was so powerful that it was
Speaker 1: his physical presence, it was being in his
Speaker 1: physical presence, it was the being in his
Speaker 1: physical presence that made the immediacy
Speaker 1: of the awakening to the timeless and
Speaker 1: formless and beginningless and endless
Speaker 1: nature of consciousness so tangible and so
Speaker 1: possible and many people not just myself
Speaker 1: but many people as a result of sitting in
Speaker 1: his presence and trusting him, that
Speaker 1: powerful realization of enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness.
Speaker 1: So there's two fundamental approaches to
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: One is the gradual path, which tells us
Speaker 1: that if you practice a particular technique
Speaker 1: in the context of a particular philosophy
Speaker 1: consistently over a long period of time,
Speaker 1: you'll eventually get there, you'll
Speaker 1: eventually become enlightened and realize
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: The path of sudden awakening says
Speaker 1: enlightenment is your own true nature, it's
Speaker 1: your natural state and it's always already
Speaker 1: the case.
Speaker 1: Realize it now.
Speaker 1: Realize that there's nothing in the way and
Speaker 1: there never has been anything in the way.
Speaker 1: And if you can do that, if you can realize
Speaker 1: there's nothing in the way, then suddenly
Speaker 1: nothing is in the way.
Speaker 1: And when you have that kind of experience
Speaker 1: you realize that it didn't need to take so
Speaker 1: much time.
Speaker 1: I had been practicing meditation very
Speaker 1: diligently for about eight or nine years
Speaker 1: before I met my guru and I spent 10 minutes
Speaker 1: in his presence and it happened.
Speaker 1: Now, usually how it goes is that the those
Speaker 1: who are advocates of sudden awakening, the
Speaker 1: path of sudden awakening mock, tend to mock
Speaker 1: those paths that preach gradual awakening
Speaker 1: and the similar way the path of gradual
Speaker 1: awakening than to mock the path of sudden
Speaker 1: awakening.
Speaker 1: Now, in my own case, after teaching for 35
Speaker 1: years and meeting a lot of people and
Speaker 1: seeing a lot of people go through this kind
Speaker 1: of process, I've come to the conclusion
Speaker 1: that I believe both of these approaches are
Speaker 1: necessary in order to embrace a complete
Speaker 1: path of awakening.
Speaker 1: So, as I'm fond of saying, awakening is
Speaker 1: easy, staying awake is very difficult.
Speaker 1: It's much easier to awaken initially than
Speaker 1: it is to stay awake, and I can't tell you
Speaker 1: how many times I've met people who've told
Speaker 1: me I had the most amazing experience of
Speaker 1: awakening at a particular point in my life
Speaker 1: and then I lost touch with it.
Speaker 1: When we have a profound awakening, we lose
Speaker 1: touch with it.
Speaker 1: We find ourselves very lost at sea, not
Speaker 1: really sure where to go or what to do or
Speaker 1: how to get back to where we thought we were.
Speaker 1: So it's my belief, it's my opinion that
Speaker 1: unless we have a profound experience of
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness, unless
Speaker 1: we really have an experience of waking up
Speaker 1: that is radical, radical and explosive that
Speaker 1: it will be, unless we do that, it will be
Speaker 1: very difficult to practice the path, the
Speaker 1: gradual path, because many people who are
Speaker 1: long-term meditators, who haven't become
Speaker 1: enlightened yet or haven't gained access to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness becometerm meditators.
Speaker 1: Who haven't become enlightened yet or
Speaker 1: haven't gained access to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness become good meditators.
Speaker 1: But they've given up on the goal which is
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: And I'm sure all of you remember the very
Speaker 1: famous Zen phrase saying that says don't
Speaker 1: mistake the finger for the moon.
Speaker 1: The moon represents enlightenment.
Speaker 1: Meditation is the finger pointing to moon.
Speaker 1: The moon represents enlightenment,
Speaker 1: meditation is the finger pointing to it.
Speaker 1: Don't mistake the finger for the moon,
Speaker 1: don't mistake the practice of meditation
Speaker 1: for enlightenment itself.
Speaker 1: So I believe that unless we are in some way
Speaker 1: grounded as a result of having deep
Speaker 1: experiences, unless we're grounded in a
Speaker 1: deep recognition of enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: unless we are deeply grounded in a faith
Speaker 1: about the fact that enlightenment is real,
Speaker 1: based upon what we've experienced ourself,
Speaker 1: it's going to be very difficult, I think,
Speaker 1: to sustain a passionate and enthusiastic
Speaker 1: meditation practice and process over a long
Speaker 1: period of time.
Speaker 1: Because our practice, unless the meditation
Speaker 1: practice is deeply connected to our
Speaker 1: awakening experientially in the present
Speaker 1: moment, what tends to happen is the
Speaker 1: meditation process tends to get dry and
Speaker 1: uninspired.
Speaker 1: When I began teaching in 1986, shortly
Speaker 1: after I met my guru, many people were
Speaker 1: having very dramatic awakening experiences
Speaker 1: very quickly and very suddenly all over the
Speaker 1: place and it was quite something to behold.
Speaker 1: It was miraculous, glorious, extraordinary
Speaker 1: and so deeply inspiring.
Speaker 1: We called in those days, people were
Speaker 1: popping and I, wrongly, was beginning to
Speaker 1: think that if this miracle kept happening,
Speaker 1: that the world would never be the same.
Speaker 1: So what I noticed was happening was that
Speaker 1: people were having these dramatic
Speaker 1: enlightenment, awakening experiences.
Speaker 1: But I started to notice over time that they
Speaker 1: so I've to notice over time that they that
Speaker 1: unsupported by my presence, that their
Speaker 1: awakening unsupported by my physical
Speaker 1: presence, that if their access to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness was not supported by
Speaker 1: my physical presence, most people over a
Speaker 1: period of time, eventually would fall out
Speaker 1: of that state and lose access to what they
Speaker 1: knew.
Speaker 1: Because I thought in those days that what
Speaker 1: had happened to me when I met my guru had
Speaker 1: happened to them.
Speaker 1: It seemed like they were experiencing the
Speaker 1: same dramatic shift in consciousness that I
Speaker 1: did when I met my guru, but I started to
Speaker 1: find out over a period of months they were
Speaker 1: experiencing the same dramatic shift in
Speaker 1: consciousness that I did when I met my guru,
Speaker 1: but I started to find out over a period of
Speaker 1: months that it didn't seem to be quite the
Speaker 1: same, that they had a similar experience,
Speaker 1: but the long-term result of a stabilized
Speaker 1: awakening was not the case, was not the
Speaker 1: case.
Speaker 1: It was not the outcome.
Speaker 1: So when I started teaching, I was a strict
Speaker 1: teacher of the sudden path.
Speaker 1: I actually told people when they were
Speaker 1: coming to me, if they were meditators, to
Speaker 1: stop meditating, because I said, if you
Speaker 1: think that meditating is going to get you
Speaker 1: there, then you're waiting.
Speaker 1: I was very radical myself in those days.
Speaker 1: I said if you think meditation is going to
Speaker 1: help you to get somewhere that you aren't
Speaker 1: already, you need to wait for something to
Speaker 1: happen, and if you're waiting, you're never
Speaker 1: going gonna get there.
Speaker 1: You have to stop waiting.
Speaker 1: When should I stop waiting?
Speaker 1: You need to stop waiting right now.
Speaker 1: That's when things got interesting and kind
Speaker 1: of exciting and people would begin to
Speaker 1: consider what would it be like to stop
Speaker 1: waiting to awaken?
Speaker 1: But in any case, I can't remember how long
Speaker 1: it took me Maybe it was a year or so, I
Speaker 1: can't remember how long but at a certain
Speaker 1: point it dawned on me that this process of
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness and the
Speaker 1: completeness and fullness of this kind of
Speaker 1: transformation was not necessarily going to
Speaker 1: be so easy for most people as it had
Speaker 1: apparently been for me, and I realized that
Speaker 1: we all have to work our way through this.
Speaker 1: We all have to learn how to learn to
Speaker 1: understand the human condition by
Speaker 1: struggling to understand it, by struggling
Speaker 1: to understand it, and we all needed to make
Speaker 1: the effort to struggle to get to know
Speaker 1: ourselves on a personal level and on a
Speaker 1: spiritual level.
Speaker 1: We needed to do the very hard work, the
Speaker 1: hard spiritual work, of understanding
Speaker 1: ourselves emotionally and psychologically,
Speaker 1: and also we needed to have the experience
Speaker 1: of these higher states of consciousness
Speaker 1: that would reveal the absolute nature of
Speaker 1: reality to us and change our relationship
Speaker 1: for life forever.
Speaker 1: But I realized that this was not a matter
Speaker 1: of snapping one's fingers.
Speaker 1: That will change our relationship for life
Speaker 1: forever.
Speaker 1: But I realized that this is not a matter of
Speaker 1: snapping one's fingers.
Speaker 1: It was not.
Speaker 1: For most people, it wasn't a matter of an
Speaker 1: instantaneous recognition.
Speaker 1: It would lead to a stabilized result.
Speaker 1: This is something we all needed to be
Speaker 1: working on continuously and perpetually.
Speaker 1: So after a while, I started telling my
Speaker 1: students, teaching them and telling them to
Speaker 1: begin to meditate a lot, and so I taught
Speaker 1: them how to meditate and how to practice
Speaker 1: the art not only of meditation, but also
Speaker 1: contemplation and introspection Meditation,
Speaker 1: contemplation, introspection, and so I
Speaker 1: wanted everybody to learn how to awaken, to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness.
Speaker 1: But I also wanted everybody to learn how to
Speaker 1: be an awakened human being, which meant
Speaker 1: learning how to be vulnerable, learning how
Speaker 1: to be transparent, learning how to be
Speaker 1: authentic, learning how to have soul level
Speaker 1: integrity.
Speaker 1: Most people don't know how to do those
Speaker 1: things and I realized that this all needs
Speaker 1: to be worked on.
Speaker 1: Most of us need to work on our own
Speaker 1: transformation perpetually.
Speaker 1: Most of the greatest musicians practice all
Speaker 1: the time.
Speaker 1: Now, for me, ever since I've been 22, this
Speaker 1: matter of what is enlightenment and my
Speaker 1: interest in it has been the driving passion
Speaker 1: in my life and it remains to be the case.
Speaker 1: So I'm kind of obsessed with this question
Speaker 1: about what is enlightenment For most people.
Speaker 1: Their interest in enlightenment usually
Speaker 1: tends to be a passing fancy, something we
Speaker 1: become interested in for a certain period
Speaker 1: of time and a certain period in our life.
Speaker 1: We might become fascinated by the
Speaker 1: possibility, but often life circumstances
Speaker 1: change or we may get distracted by some
Speaker 1: kind of event or desire, get distracted
Speaker 1: away from this primary motivation and
Speaker 1: primary goal, and we forget about it for a
Speaker 1: period of time or maybe forever.
Speaker 1: So I've come to the conclusion that, if
Speaker 1: we're going to go deep and we're going to
Speaker 1: stay deep, then I'm not ashamed to say that
Speaker 1: I believe embracing this kind of spiritual
Speaker 1: process needs to become an obsession, and
Speaker 1: why shouldn't that be the case?
Speaker 1: Why shouldn't it be true?
Speaker 1: Now, what I wanted to speak about today was
Speaker 1: the good news, which is the fact that we
Speaker 1: there's a lot of help available for us.
Speaker 1: There have been many great human beings who
Speaker 1: have walked this path before us and have
Speaker 1: gone very far and very deep, and so there's
Speaker 1: so much information available to us that
Speaker 1: it's extraordinary.
Speaker 1: We're very lucky.
Speaker 1: So if we can liberate ourselves from a
Speaker 1: conscious and unconscious, irrational,
Speaker 1: egoic reluctance to give ourselves to the
Speaker 1: process of awakening, there's so much
Speaker 1: information available to us that can help
Speaker 1: us wake up.
Speaker 1: Once you wake up, it becomes very obvious
Speaker 1: how to do this.
Speaker 1: Before one wakes up, it's not so obvious.
Speaker 1: I don't know if many of you have heard of
Speaker 1: the great spirit, the great 20th century
Speaker 1: spiritual master, j Krishnamurti, but he
Speaker 1: was such a powerful realizer, but when
Speaker 1: people were listening to him, most people
Speaker 1: could never understand what he was talking
Speaker 1: about, and I remember when I would read
Speaker 1: books by about the teachings of Ramana
Speaker 1: Maharshi and other great non-dual realizers,
Speaker 1: I never quite could figure out what they
Speaker 1: were saying.
Speaker 1: I mean I, it was beautiful and it attracted
Speaker 1: me, but I didn't understand it.
Speaker 1: But after I spent some time with my guru
Speaker 1: and had a life-changing awakening, suddenly
Speaker 1: it was all I could understand it.
Speaker 1: I could understand what they were saying.
Speaker 1: But after I spent some time with my guru
Speaker 1: and had a life-changing awakening, suddenly
Speaker 1: it was all I could understand it.
Speaker 1: I could understand what they were saying
Speaker 1: because I knew where they were speaking
Speaker 1: from and it was all very clear.
Speaker 1: In order to understand what awakening is
Speaker 1: all about, we've got to do it.
Speaker 1: The more we do it, the more we understand.
Speaker 1: The more we do it, the more we have access
Speaker 1: to the source of awakening, consciousness
Speaker 1: itself.
Speaker 1: And then it becomes very easy for us and
Speaker 1: very palpable.
Speaker 1: Now I teach enlightenment in an interesting,
Speaker 1: slightly complex context, because I divide
Speaker 1: enlightenment into two expressions.
Speaker 1: I make a distinction between what I call
Speaker 1: being enlightened, being enlightened, being
Speaker 1: enlightened is the enlightenment of the
Speaker 1: Buddha, is the enlightenment of the great
Speaker 1: Eckhart Tolle, is the awakening to what
Speaker 1: Eckhart Tolle calls the ground of being
Speaker 1: what the Buddha called the uncreated and
Speaker 1: the unborn.
Speaker 1: It's also grounded being what the Buddha
Speaker 1: called the uncreated and the unborn being.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment is awakening to that
Speaker 1: mysterious depth dimension that exists
Speaker 1: prior to time, prior to space, prior to the
Speaker 1: emergence of the universe.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to that primordial emptiness,
Speaker 1: or that primordial vacuum of no-thingness
Speaker 1: or nothingness, infinite nothingness, where
Speaker 1: there's no time and there's no space and
Speaker 1: there's no mind.
Speaker 1: There's just emptiness.
Speaker 1: Because that emptiness exists before time
Speaker 1: and before space and before the universe
Speaker 1: ever existed.
Speaker 1: It's a place and a space of unconditional,
Speaker 1: unimaginable, inconceivable freedom,
Speaker 1: inconceivable freedom.
Speaker 1: It's a space of inconceivable freedom
Speaker 1: because before the universe was created,
Speaker 1: nothing had ever happened.
Speaker 1: Before nothing had ever happened.
Speaker 1: Before anything had ever happened, nothing
Speaker 1: was wrong, nothing could be wrong.
Speaker 1: So it's awakening to this depth dimension
Speaker 1: that the Buddha called the uncreated and
Speaker 1: the unborn, the Ramana called the self,
Speaker 1: that Akartoli calls the ground of being.
Speaker 1: That's the source of the traditional
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: When we awaken to the ground of being, to
Speaker 1: the self, to that which is uncreated, we
Speaker 1: experience that peace that passes all
Speaker 1: understanding.
Speaker 1: And the reason we do is because before the
Speaker 1: universe was created there was only peace.
Speaker 1: Nothing had happened.
Speaker 1: Yet.
Speaker 1: I think we should just try and imagine how
Speaker 1: peaceful would it be if nothing had ever
Speaker 1: happened yet, if the evolving universe had
Speaker 1: not even emerged in the mind of God, yet as
Speaker 1: an idea.
Speaker 1: How peaceful would it be?
Speaker 1: It's unimaginably, inconceivably peaceful.
Speaker 1: So it's the experience of that kind of
Speaker 1: unimaginable, inconceivable peace that we
Speaker 1: seek our release from suffering and from
Speaker 1: ignorance and from bondage.
Speaker 1: In this traditional approach to the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment and the way the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment to break it down and make it
Speaker 1: very simple, the way the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment works is the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment is usually approached through
Speaker 1: transcending the mind, learning how to let
Speaker 1: go of the mind.
Speaker 1: So the way the being Enlightenment works is
Speaker 1: Very simply, through letting go.
Speaker 1: Can you or I let go of our mind?
Speaker 1: The mind is not just thought, but it's the
Speaker 1: realm of your personal identity.
Speaker 1: It's where our, it's the realm of our fears
Speaker 1: and our desires.
Speaker 1: It's the place where the story of our
Speaker 1: personal ego abides.
Speaker 1: It's a small little world that the ego
Speaker 1: creates and the ego lives in.
Speaker 1: It's a place of enormous suffering and an
Speaker 1: immense experience of inner contraction.
Speaker 1: It's a place of very little inner freedom
Speaker 1: and very little love.
Speaker 1: It's a place of alienation, isolation and
Speaker 1: separation.
Speaker 1: It's the abode of the small self.
Speaker 1: So when we make that flip from small self
Speaker 1: to big self, from ego to being, the ego,
Speaker 1: suddenly disappears.
Speaker 1: The ego's world disappears Suddenly.
Speaker 1: It's as if the ego's world never existed,
Speaker 1: and we delight in experiencing a state of
Speaker 1: eternal freedom, eternal freedom, freedom
Speaker 1: that is eternal, that is beginningless and
Speaker 1: endless and timeless and formless.
Speaker 1: So when we awaken to the presence of the
Speaker 1: eternal or eternity, so when we awaken to
Speaker 1: the presence of the eternal or eternity, we
Speaker 1: experience a profound sense of liberation
Speaker 1: that is intoxicating beyond imagination.
Speaker 1: It's a place of such joy that we don't want
Speaker 1: to return from, and this is why men and
Speaker 1: women have been leading the world for
Speaker 1: millennia to be able to abide in the state
Speaker 1: of consciousness.
Speaker 1: So people have been sitting in caves and
Speaker 1: sitting on mountain tops and sitting in the
Speaker 1: forest and getting away from the world to
Speaker 1: experience this kind of glorious, ecstatic
Speaker 1: freedom and happiness.
Speaker 1: So the way to attain the enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness of being, or the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment, is through letting go of
Speaker 1: anything and everything that's in our way.
Speaker 1: So how this would work is, let's say you're
Speaker 1: sitting in meditation, you go very deep,
Speaker 1: you realize in a sudden and immediate way
Speaker 1: that you're attached to something, to a
Speaker 1: painful experience, to a bad relationship,
Speaker 1: to a wrong idea, whatever it is.
Speaker 1: You realize it and you see for yourself
Speaker 1: that you're attached to a wrong
Speaker 1: relationship, to a wrong idea, whatever it
Speaker 1: is.
Speaker 1: You realize and you see for yourself that
Speaker 1: you're attached.
Speaker 1: You can feel it.
Speaker 1: You can feel the contractions, you can feel
Speaker 1: the tightness.
Speaker 1: So what should you do then?
Speaker 1: All you've got to do is let go In
Speaker 1: approaching being enlightenment.
Speaker 1: All we have to do is let go.
Speaker 1: So the access point to awakening, to being
Speaker 1: enlightenment the enlightenment that the
Speaker 1: Buddhas taught, the enlightenment that
Speaker 1: Ramana Harshi was radiating, the
Speaker 1: enlightenment that my teacher taught me is
Speaker 1: the being enlightenment.
Speaker 1: The way to reach being enlightenment is by
Speaker 1: letting go of anything that's in its way,
Speaker 1: especially our attachment to the mind and
Speaker 1: its contents.
Speaker 1: The mind and its contents that is connected
Speaker 1: with the ego is a place of overwhelming
Speaker 1: attachment and identification.
Speaker 1: So you say what do I do about it?
Speaker 1: The only thing to do about it is you want
Speaker 1: to be free.
Speaker 1: If you want to be free, it's to let go of
Speaker 1: all of it.
Speaker 1: When, sometime around now and I want to
Speaker 1: make clear to all of you that that's all
Speaker 1: there is to it Isn't it more complicated?
Speaker 1: No, it's not the only thing.
Speaker 1: If you want to awaken to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness in the context of being
Speaker 1: enlightened, all you have to do.
Speaker 1: All one has to do is to let go of anything
Speaker 1: that's in the way.
Speaker 1: What's in the Fear and attachment, fear,
Speaker 1: desire, identification and attachment, fear,
Speaker 1: desire, identification and attachment To
Speaker 1: this or to that Doesn't matter what it is,
Speaker 1: it's whatever keeps you unfree, whatever
Speaker 1: keeps you unfree and attached and dug in
Speaker 1: and trapped and spiritually suffocated and
Speaker 1: anything less than totally free and totally
Speaker 1: liberated.
Speaker 1: So it needs to be relinquished.
Speaker 1: Our attachment to it needs to be
Speaker 1: relinquished.
Speaker 1: So all we have to do if we want to awaken
Speaker 1: to being enlightenment, is to let go of
Speaker 1: anything that is in the way.
Speaker 1: That's all we have to do.
Speaker 1: Easier said than done, obviously.
Speaker 1: I realize that it might be easier said than
Speaker 1: done, but it is that easy Because when we
Speaker 1: think about enlightenment, we want to make
Speaker 1: it very complicated.
Speaker 1: There must be more to it.
Speaker 1: There has to be some complex puzzle that I
Speaker 1: need to understand here.
Speaker 1: There must be more to it.
Speaker 1: There has to be some complex puzzle that I
Speaker 1: need to understand here.
Speaker 1: There must be some complex metaphysical
Speaker 1: process that I need to understand and I
Speaker 1: need to work through in order to get there
Speaker 1: to say no.
Speaker 1: All you've got to do is let go and
Speaker 1: everything will become clear to you.
Speaker 1: So it's the letting go part that's so
Speaker 1: challenging.
Speaker 1: It's the letting go part that's so
Speaker 1: But letting go is simply what it is.
Speaker 1: There's nothing more to it than what it is.
Speaker 1: Letting go is letting go.
Speaker 1: There's nothing more to it.
Speaker 1: There's nothing more to it than becomes
Speaker 1: apparent to us when we think about what is
Speaker 1: letting go.
Speaker 1: It's letting go of our attachment to
Speaker 1: whatever it is.
Speaker 1: If you let go of attachment, you will be
Speaker 1: free and you will awaken to the ground of
Speaker 1: being, and you know exactly what Eckhart
Speaker 1: Tolle so passionately speaks about all the
Speaker 1: time.
Speaker 1: So I wanted to emphasize how simple this is
Speaker 1: and how profound it is.
Speaker 1: If you want to awaken to the enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness that the Buddha was calling us to,
Speaker 1: if you want to know what Ramana Maharshi
Speaker 1: was speaking about and pointing to, all
Speaker 1: you've got to do is let go of your mind,
Speaker 1: let your ego.
Speaker 1: Easier said than done.
Speaker 1: Sure, it might be easier said than done,
Speaker 1: and it is easier said than done, but in the
Speaker 1: end, that's all there is to it.
Speaker 1: That's my point.
Speaker 1: It couldn't be that simple.
Speaker 1: Yes, it is that simple.
Speaker 1: That's my main point.
Speaker 1: You mean, letting go is all there is to it?
Speaker 1: Yes, but letting go is hard?
Speaker 1: It might be, but just because letting go is
Speaker 1: hard doesn't mean you can't do it.
Speaker 1: There's something to me.
Speaker 1: There's something infinitely compelling, so
Speaker 1: deeply satisfying and gratifying and also
Speaker 1: humiliating, about the radical simplicity
Speaker 1: involved in this whole process.
Speaker 1: You mean, all I've got to do is let go.
Speaker 1: Yes, that's all you've got to do.
Speaker 1: And someone says, well, how do I do that?
Speaker 1: I say, well, how do you think?
Speaker 1: Is there something?
Speaker 1: I don't.
Speaker 1: How do I let go?
Speaker 1: Just let go.
Speaker 1: And when people say they don't know how to
Speaker 1: let go, I don't believe them.
Speaker 1: We all know how to let go.
Speaker 1: The question is, are we ready to do it yet?
Speaker 1: Or we might not be ready, and that's a
Speaker 1: different subject.
Speaker 1: But I just want to get everybody to the
Speaker 1: point where they recognize that all that's
Speaker 1: involved is the letting go itself.
Speaker 1: So being enlightenment is what's commonly
Speaker 1: understood to be.
Speaker 1: When people use the word enlightenment,
Speaker 1: that's what they're referring to.
Speaker 1: That's what I'm calling the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: But there's another kind of enlightenment
Speaker 1: which is equally valuable and equally
Speaker 1: profound, which is relatively new.
Speaker 1: It's the awakening to evolution.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to the creative intelligence
Speaker 1: that's catalyzing the evolving momentum of
Speaker 1: the cosmos.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to that cosmic intelligence
Speaker 1: called Eros, the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that created the universe and is creating
Speaker 1: it right now.
Speaker 1: It's awakening directly to it.
Speaker 1: It affords us a different kind of
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to this creative
Speaker 1: intelligence, the God consciousness, the
Speaker 1: creative intelligence.
Speaker 1: That's the God consciousness that compelled
Speaker 1: the universe into existence and that's
Speaker 1: compelling us to exist now.
Speaker 1: That's compelling us forward in time, it's
Speaker 1: the source of all creativity.
Speaker 1: That's why I call it evolutionary
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: It's the awakening to evolution.
Speaker 1: And the great realizers, like the Catholic
Speaker 1: priest Thierry de Chardin, the great
Speaker 1: Eastern realizer and genius, sri Aurobindo,
Speaker 1: awakened evolution.
Speaker 1: And this is a different kind of
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: This, in this enlightenment, we become
Speaker 1: aware of this.
Speaker 1: The momentum, the living, vibrating
Speaker 1: momentum of the creative intelligence that
Speaker 1: gave rise to the universe and it's giving
Speaker 1: rise to it right now.
Speaker 1: That creative intelligence is moving, is on
Speaker 1: a journey of becoming and it's compelling
Speaker 1: all of us towards the future.
Speaker 1: And the experience of this kind of cosmic,
Speaker 1: creative intelligence is not peace.
Speaker 1: It doesn't feel peaceful.
Speaker 1: It's the experience of an ecstatic creative
Speaker 1: urgency.
Speaker 1: urgency that's compelling us at an
Speaker 1: unthinkable momentum towards the future.
Speaker 1: So the most profound acts of creativity
Speaker 1: occur because of this momentum that I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about.
Speaker 1: Because of this momentum that I'm speaking
Speaker 1: about, all creativity is possible only
Speaker 1: because of that.
Speaker 1: And so when you awaken to this creative
Speaker 1: intelligence itself directly, we experience
Speaker 1: an ecstatic urgency and an overwhelming
Speaker 1: sense of positivity.
Speaker 1: There's a sense that anything is possible,
Speaker 1: all things are possible.
Speaker 1: All things are possible.
Speaker 1: All things are possible because we're awake
Speaker 1: to a sense of infinite greater potential,
Speaker 1: that is, one with the source of creation
Speaker 1: itself.
Speaker 1: We become conscious of it.
Speaker 1: Becoming conscious of it is what
Speaker 1: evolutionary enlightenment is all about.
Speaker 1: It's awakening to us a tremendous power.
Speaker 1: Tremendous power, tremendous freedom, and
Speaker 1: one experiences ecstasy because all things
Speaker 1: feel possible.
Speaker 1: When all things feel possible, when all
Speaker 1: things feel possible creatively, you feel
Speaker 1: unbound.
Speaker 1: Unbound, it's a sense of unlimited
Speaker 1: potential.
Speaker 1: It's the conscious experience and awakening
Speaker 1: to the infinite potential that's driving
Speaker 1: this entire process.
Speaker 1: Like so, you realize that what's compelling
Speaker 1: the energy and intelligence that's creating
Speaker 1: the universe and compelling the universe to
Speaker 1: exist, its nature is pure positivity, and
Speaker 1: when you experience that pure positivity
Speaker 1: directly, you'll know it Because it'll be
Speaker 1: the deepest and most profound experience
Speaker 1: you've ever had.
Speaker 1: When that happens, we know that to exist is
Speaker 1: good.
Speaker 1: We know that when God created the universe
Speaker 1: it was a big yes, and it still is and that
Speaker 1: changes your life forever.
Speaker 1: So, in this evolutionary enlightenment
Speaker 1: versus the being enlightenment, how do we
Speaker 1: awaken to evolutionary enlightenment?
Speaker 1: By becoming very interested in it, by
Speaker 1: becoming very interested in it.
Speaker 1: But in order to catalyze the becoming
Speaker 1: enlightenment, the evolutionary becoming
Speaker 1: enlightenment is, we need to realize it, we
Speaker 1: need to have a realization of it and then,
Speaker 1: in order to catalyze its deepening,
Speaker 1: catalyze its continuity, we need to respond
Speaker 1: fearlessly and passionately to what we've
Speaker 1: realized In evolutionary awakening and in
Speaker 1: evolutionary enlightenment.
Speaker 1: We need to realize and respond.
Speaker 1: We need to awaken to this cosmic energy and
Speaker 1: intelligence and then respond to what
Speaker 1: you've realized, realize and awaken to this
Speaker 1: creative intelligence that's catalyzing the
Speaker 1: momentum of the evolving cosmos, and
Speaker 1: respond to it.
Speaker 1: Respond.
Speaker 1: We have to continuously realize and respond.
Speaker 1: If we realize it, we don't respond to it,
Speaker 1: it will fall away from us.
Speaker 1: If you realize and awaken to evolution, if
Speaker 1: you awaken to the evolutionary impulse and
Speaker 1: don't respond to it, the tangible sense of
Speaker 1: the evolutionary impulse will fall away
Speaker 1: from you.
Speaker 1: But if you realize it and respond to it,
Speaker 1: act from it, its vibration will get
Speaker 1: stronger within you.
Speaker 1: And if you continue to realize and respond
Speaker 1: to what you've been realizing, its
Speaker 1: vibration will get stronger and stronger
Speaker 1: and stronger.
Speaker 1: So what's very, very interesting is that in
Speaker 1: being enlightenment, in the enlightenment
Speaker 1: in which we awaken to timeless, formless,
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless being, we need to
Speaker 1: realize being and let go, awaken to
Speaker 1: timeless, formless, beginningless and
Speaker 1: endless eternal being and let go and
Speaker 1: continue to let go To have nothing, know
Speaker 1: nothing and be no one, to continue to let
Speaker 1: go eternally, continuously, again and again
Speaker 1: and again.
Speaker 1: Letting go is freedom.
Speaker 1: In being enlightenment, letting go is
Speaker 1: freedom.
Speaker 1: I repeat, in being enlightenment, letting
Speaker 1: go is freedom.
Speaker 1: But in evolutionary enlightenment or
Speaker 1: becoming enlightenment, freedom only comes
Speaker 1: from responding or the response to what
Speaker 1: we've realized.
Speaker 1: In becoming enlightenment, it's realize and
Speaker 1: respond, realize and act, realize and take
Speaker 1: action, realize and take action, realize
Speaker 1: and take action.
Speaker 1: The only way the universe will continue to
Speaker 1: evolve at the level of consciousness is
Speaker 1: when human beings realize, awaken to and
Speaker 1: realize the evolutionary impulse and
Speaker 1: respond to the gift of incarnation in that
Speaker 1: knowledge.
Speaker 1: Then we need to realize and respond to what
Speaker 1: we've realized again and again and again
Speaker 1: and again.
Speaker 1: And if we continue to respond and our
Speaker 1: responses are powerful and are coming from
Speaker 1: the source, then the universe will evolve
Speaker 1: and be changed and affected as a result of
Speaker 1: our response.
Speaker 1: The more I in evolutionary enlightenment,
Speaker 1: the more I realize and respond, and the
Speaker 1: more you realize and respond, the more the
Speaker 1: interior of the universe will be affected
Speaker 1: by our realization.
Speaker 1: So the profound distinction I wanted to
Speaker 1: make in this talk was this very simple
Speaker 1: teaching that makes this profound
Speaker 1: distinction, which is that in being,
Speaker 1: enlightenment enlightenment of the Buddha,
Speaker 1: the enlightenment of Ramamaharshi, the
Speaker 1: enlightenment of Akartali is directly
Speaker 1: experienced when we realize and let go of
Speaker 1: the mind and of the fears and desires of
Speaker 1: the separate personality, realize and let
Speaker 1: go.
Speaker 1: I want to be enlightened, then let go.
Speaker 1: I want to know what the Buddha did, I want
Speaker 1: to know what the Buddha did.
Speaker 1: So let go Now.
Speaker 1: Let go now.
Speaker 1: Let go of the story now, let go of your
Speaker 1: mind now.
Speaker 1: And then, of course, there's the ego's
Speaker 1: reluctance.
Speaker 1: And until the ego's reluctance is defeated
Speaker 1: or transcended, the one access to being
Speaker 1: won't be granted.
Speaker 1: But when you transcend your own ego's
Speaker 1: reluctance, then you find access to the
Speaker 1: ground of being and you get an infinite
Speaker 1: reward.
Speaker 1: It is eternal peace and eternal freedom,
Speaker 1: the freedom of knowing you've never been
Speaker 1: born.
Speaker 1: And if you know you've never been born, you
Speaker 1: know you're never going to die.
Speaker 1: That's the idea and it's also the
Speaker 1: experience, the gift of evolutionary, the
Speaker 1: gift that evolutionary enlightenment gives
Speaker 1: us, awakening to the evolutionary impulses,
Speaker 1: the gift of knowing who I am and why I'm
Speaker 1: here.
Speaker 1: When you awaken to the evolutionary impulse,
Speaker 1: you realize I am the energy and
Speaker 1: intelligence that created the universe,
Speaker 1: awakening to itself through the body-mind
Speaker 1: personality of, in my case, andrew.
Speaker 1: I am the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe, awakening to itself
Speaker 1: through the body-mind personality of Andrew,
Speaker 1: of my very own self.
Speaker 1: And now I've discovered the internet
Speaker 1: context from my presence here in the
Speaker 1: universe.
Speaker 1: I'm the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe and I'm here, through
Speaker 1: the vehicle of this body-mind and
Speaker 1: personality, to create the future.
Speaker 1: That's my reason to exist, from the
Speaker 1: perspective of enlightenment.
Speaker 1: I'm not here to have and to get and to
Speaker 1: become for myself.
Speaker 1: I'm not here to narcissistically and
Speaker 1: egotistically live this human incarnation
Speaker 1: for myself, have, get and become for me.
Speaker 1: I'm here to help co-create the interior of
Speaker 1: the universe as the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that gave rise to it in the first place.
Speaker 1: That's why I exist, that's why I exist,
Speaker 1: that's why I exist and that's why you exist.
Speaker 1: And you know that when you realize that,
Speaker 1: when you recognize that changes your life,
Speaker 1: so many smart, intelligent, sensitive,
Speaker 1: thoughtful, intelligent people suffer so
Speaker 1: much despair and lean towards nihilistic
Speaker 1: inclinations because they don't know why
Speaker 1: they exist.
Speaker 1: They don't know why they're here.
Speaker 1: They don't know why the universe exists.
Speaker 1: So if you're here in this frail body and
Speaker 1: sensitive mind and you don't know why
Speaker 1: you're here, you live in a state of
Speaker 1: ambivalence about being here.
Speaker 1: But when you have no doubt who you are, you
Speaker 1: have no doubt why you're here, you
Speaker 1: experience enormous gratitude at the
Speaker 1: privilege of being able to play such an
Speaker 1: important part in this whole process.
Speaker 1: I know who I am and I know why I'm here.
Speaker 1: That changes everything.
Speaker 1: So being enlightenment is realize and let
Speaker 1: go Infinitely, let go eternally and
Speaker 1: infinitely.
Speaker 1: Becoming enlightenment is realize and
Speaker 1: respond.
Speaker 1: When Now, realize and let go, realize and
Speaker 1: So think about that.
Speaker 1: That's very easy to understand and, as I
Speaker 1: said at the beginning of my talk, I want to
Speaker 1: help demystify how all this works.
Speaker 1: So you're telling me, if I want to know
Speaker 1: what the Buddha knew, I want to awaken to
Speaker 1: the ground of being that Eckhart Tolle
Speaker 1: speaks about so passionately, that all I
Speaker 1: need to do is realize and let go.
Speaker 1: Yes, of my fear and attachment.
Speaker 1: Yes, you mean there's nothing more involved.
Speaker 1: No, anybody can do it.
Speaker 1: Yes, even I can do it.
Speaker 1: Yes, beautiful, we end up having no excuses
Speaker 1: anymore.
Speaker 1: Why aren't you enlightened yet?
Speaker 1: If it's that easy, we all should be well on
Speaker 1: our way now.
Speaker 1: It's really not any more complicated than
Speaker 1: what I'm saying.
Speaker 1: It seems complicated from the ego's
Speaker 1: perspective, from the part of you that has
Speaker 1: no interest in enlightenment in the first
Speaker 1: place.
Speaker 1: It seems endlessly complicated From the
Speaker 1: part of you that always only wanted that.
Speaker 1: It's very immediate and very simple and
Speaker 1: very direct.
Speaker 1: Being enlightenment is realize and let go.
Speaker 1: Becoming enlightenment is realize and let
Speaker 1: go.
Speaker 1: Becoming enlightenment is realize and
Speaker 1: respond, realize and respond, realize and
Speaker 1: respond.
Speaker 1: And once you understand the way being
Speaker 1: enlightenment works together with becoming
Speaker 1: enlightenment, then this information of
Speaker 1: realizing and letting go and realizing and
Speaker 1: responding becomes very useful.
Speaker 1: Now, what I'm describing to you needs to be.
Speaker 1: Remember what I said before.
Speaker 1: If we want to cultivate a very deep access
Speaker 1: to these higher states of consciousness,
Speaker 1: it's something we need to be working on
Speaker 1: consistently, continuously, perpetually,
Speaker 1: just like a master musician would be
Speaker 1: working on their musical facility.
Speaker 1: Some musicians practice Eight hours a day,
Speaker 1: ten hours a day.
Speaker 1: I think about this stuff sixteen hours a
Speaker 1: day.
Speaker 1: It's always in my mind, sometimes with more
Speaker 1: intensity, sometimes with less intensity,
Speaker 1: but this never leaves my consciousness
Speaker 1: Because I'm living for this.
Speaker 1: Nobody's forcing me to do it.
Speaker 1: This is what I've chosen to give my life to,
Speaker 1: so it's my eternal obsession.
Speaker 1: So can we learn?
Speaker 1: So my understanding of living a spiritual
Speaker 1: life in earnest, in the context of
Speaker 1: awakening to enlightened awareness, is we
Speaker 1: want to all perpetually work on realizing
Speaker 1: and letting go.
Speaker 1: Realizing and letting go every day.
Speaker 1: Realizing and letting go, continuing to
Speaker 1: realize and let go so we get better and
Speaker 1: better at it.
Speaker 1: The better added you, the better out.
Speaker 1: If you get, the more authentic, the more
Speaker 1: truly authentic your enlightenment will
Speaker 1: appear to be.
Speaker 1: But you can't fake this.
Speaker 1: I guess some people can, some people do,
Speaker 1: but you can't really fake it because if you
Speaker 1: are truly free, you realize the natural
Speaker 1: state.
Speaker 1: If you realize the natural state, you will
Speaker 1: manifest and express lightness of being.
Speaker 1: One wonderful Dutch spiritual teacher once
Speaker 1: told me many years ago.
Speaker 1: He said enlightenment is lightness of being.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment is lightness of being,
Speaker 1: lightness of your being.
Speaker 1: So the enlightened awareness is the
Speaker 1: experience of lightness of being.
Speaker 1: If you're in the presence of someone who's
Speaker 1: awakened to enlightened awareness, their
Speaker 1: presence feels like lightness of being Joy,
Speaker 1: full of joy.
Speaker 1: Lightness of being is joyful, full of joy,
Speaker 1: lightness of being.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment is lightness of being.
Speaker 1: So can we practice every day, realizing the
Speaker 1: awakening and realization.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment is lightness of being.
Speaker 1: So can we practice every day, realizing the
Speaker 1: awakening and realization of timeless,
Speaker 1: formless, beginningless and endless eternal
Speaker 1: being and let go.
Speaker 1: Can we practice that every day?
Speaker 1: Can you do that Every day?
Speaker 1: Work on this letting process of letting go
Speaker 1: of the mind Every day.
Speaker 1: Working on the process of letting go of the
Speaker 1: mind every day.
Speaker 1: mind every day, working on it becoming
Speaker 1: better and better at it, becoming a master.
Speaker 1: Work towards becoming a master.
Speaker 1: You mean I have to work at this, sorry.
Speaker 1: And can we work every day on?
Speaker 1: And can we work every day on cultivating
Speaker 1: our capacity to be a living manifestation
Speaker 1: and expression of the authentic self, the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse in human form.
Speaker 1: I am the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe and is creating the
Speaker 1: universe, awakening to itself in the form
Speaker 1: of this body, mind and personality.
Speaker 1: Can I realize my evolutionary potential?
Speaker 1: Can I realize my evolutionary nature and
Speaker 1: respond to it every day?
Speaker 1: respond to it every day, as we continually
Speaker 1: respond to our evolutionary potential, it
Speaker 1: gets stronger and stronger and stronger.
Speaker 1: So then the path becomes, in this case, of
Speaker 1: evolutionary enlightenment.
Speaker 1: Would be the practice of being
Speaker 1: enlightenment, be the practice of being
Speaker 1: enlightenment and the practice of becoming
Speaker 1: enlightenment, which simply means to
Speaker 1: realize every day and let go Every day,
Speaker 1: hopefully, more and more and more,
Speaker 1: hopefully, of the big things that keep us
Speaker 1: stuck and bound and trapped and unfree.
Speaker 1: Letting go every day, more and more.
Speaker 1: Because the way this works is the more you
Speaker 1: let go, the easier it becomes to let go,
Speaker 1: and the more you let go, the more you're
Speaker 1: going to want to let go, because letting go
Speaker 1: feels good, feels great, and the more you
Speaker 1: let go, the more you're going to want to
Speaker 1: let go, because letting go feels good,
Speaker 1: feels great, feels free.
Speaker 1: And the kind of freedom I'm speaking about
Speaker 1: can't be measured, because we're going from
Speaker 1: a relative to an absolute context and we
Speaker 1: make that flip from a relative to an
Speaker 1: absolute context.
Speaker 1: You're entering into a zone which there's,
Speaker 1: no, you can't compare, it's off the scale.
Speaker 1: And in the same way, in the evolutionary
Speaker 1: context.
Speaker 1: Can I everyday realize and respond?
Speaker 1: Can I learn how to respond with more
Speaker 1: courage, with more fearless conviction,
Speaker 1: with more inspiration?
Speaker 1: How inspired are you?
Speaker 1: Are you an inspired, evolutionarily
Speaker 1: awakened soul?
Speaker 1: If your soul has awakened to evolution,
Speaker 1: that means you are vibrating with the
Speaker 1: inspiration of the evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 1: It has a certain vibration.
Speaker 1: It's an unmistakable impersonal excitement
Speaker 1: about existence.
Speaker 1: It's an impersonal excitement about
Speaker 1: existence.
Speaker 1: I'm so excited.
Speaker 1: Existence is extraordinary, profound,
Speaker 1: miraculous and it means we're consciously
Speaker 1: in touch with the miraculous nature of
Speaker 1: existence, inherently.
Speaker 1: The inherently miraculous nature of
Speaker 1: existence.
Speaker 1: We're consciously awake to it, we're in
Speaker 1: touch with it, we feel it.
Speaker 1: It inherently miraculous nature of
Speaker 1: existence.
Speaker 1: We're consciously awake to it, we're in
Speaker 1: touch with it, we feel it, it's palpable to
Speaker 1: us, it's palpable.
Speaker 1: This is someone.
Speaker 1: When this is the case, you are someone
Speaker 1: who's turned on.
Speaker 1: You're turned on by life, I'm turned on by
Speaker 1: life.
Speaker 1: And someone who's turned on by life.
Speaker 1: If you're really turned on by life, you're
Speaker 1: not just trying to be, but if you really
Speaker 1: turned on my life, then you're gonna start
Speaker 1: turning other people on, because this
Speaker 1: excitement is infectious and it's inspiring
Speaker 1: and compelling, meaningful, it's righteous.
Speaker 1: You don't want to live a boring life
Speaker 1: anymore.
Speaker 1: Materialistic life and egotistically
Speaker 1: obsessed life no more.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 1: I want to make a difference.
Speaker 1: I want the world to be a different place,
Speaker 1: because I was here.
Speaker 1: Yes, that's audacious and outrageous, but
Speaker 1: that's how we want to begin to live.
Speaker 1: Audaciously and outrageously, why not?
Speaker 1: Why live with less heroic spirit?
Speaker 1: Why do that?
Speaker 1: Too many of us are just living to survive
Speaker 1: this ordeal.
Speaker 1: Why don't we make a difference in the
Speaker 1: meantime?
Speaker 1: And if you are a, if you believe in the
Speaker 1: continuity of consciousness, if you believe
Speaker 1: in the continuity of the process, if it's
Speaker 1: become apparent to you that this process is
Speaker 1: part and parcel of a continuity, that the
Speaker 1: evolving universe, the evolving universe of
Speaker 1: a continuity with the evolving universe,
Speaker 1: the evolving universe, is a continuity, and
Speaker 1: that continuity exists on the outside as it
Speaker 1: does on the inside.
Speaker 1: If you realize that to be true, then, even
Speaker 1: if only at the intellect, you begin to
Speaker 1: understand this.
Speaker 1: It means you're part of something
Speaker 1: inconceivably vast that's on a journey of
Speaker 1: becoming, and this lifetime that we're in
Speaker 1: the midst of is a snapshot, is just a
Speaker 1: little snapshot, of what's potentially an
Speaker 1: infinite unfolding.
Speaker 1: That means we're here for the long haul,
Speaker 1: whether your ego likes it or not.
Speaker 1: If what I'm saying is true, that means
Speaker 1: we're all here for the long haul, whether
Speaker 1: your ego likes it or not.
Speaker 1: If what I'm saying is true, that means
Speaker 1: we're all here for the long haul.
Speaker 1: So, if it's true, if we're here for the
Speaker 1: long haul because we are part and parcel of
Speaker 1: a process that is inconceivably vast and
Speaker 1: potentially infinite, then it's about time
Speaker 1: we get behind it.
Speaker 1: Yes, I'm on board, baby, all the way, and
Speaker 1: not only for this lifetime, but for the
Speaker 1: next one and the next one and the next one
Speaker 1: On into the future.
Speaker 1: What keeps us, what gets us in trouble and
Speaker 1: keeps us in trouble, is our resistance.
Speaker 1: It's a resistance where we're saying no, no,
Speaker 1: no, no, no, no, please stop.
Speaker 1: This rocket ship is going to move faster
Speaker 1: and get bigger, whether you like it or I
Speaker 1: like it or not, and that's because that's
Speaker 1: the nature of the process.
Speaker 1: The process is evolving.
Speaker 1: It's in a state of becoming bigger, more
Speaker 1: complex, more profound.
Speaker 1: That's what's happening.
Speaker 1: So if we, if we are resisting this,
Speaker 1: consciously or unconsciously, we won't be,
Speaker 1: we won't be able to know this and when we
Speaker 1: stop resisting, we find and feel that this
Speaker 1: forward momentum is a source of ecstasy and,
Speaker 1: as I was saying before, overwhelming
Speaker 1: positivity.
Speaker 1: It's thrilling and it's not a thrill that's
Speaker 1: going to come to an end.
Speaker 1: This body is going to come to an end.
Speaker 1: This body's going to come to an end, but
Speaker 1: not the process that you are.
Speaker 1: The process is happening through us.
Speaker 1: So when I say realize and respond, realize
Speaker 1: that the process is happening through you,
Speaker 1: evolution is happening through you, and
Speaker 1: then respond to that and once you respond,
Speaker 1: keep responding.
Speaker 1: The more you keep responding, the process
Speaker 1: will move faster and faster through you and
Speaker 1: the process will begin to realize itself,
Speaker 1: cognize itself and take responsibility for
Speaker 1: itself through your body, mind and
Speaker 1: personality.
Speaker 1: That's when you begin to understand who and
Speaker 1: what God is all about.
Speaker 1: It's big, you can see.
Speaker 1: It will be vast, profound and so inspiring.
Speaker 1: Yeah, maybe our lives suck, but the process
Speaker 1: of life itself is extraordinary, profound
Speaker 1: and so beautiful.
Speaker 1: If our lives aren't very interesting, let's
Speaker 1: wake up.
Speaker 1: When you wake up, you'll realize life
Speaker 1: itself is so profound and so interesting,
Speaker 1: interesting beyond measure.
Speaker 1: If our lives aren't that interesting, it's
Speaker 1: because we have our attention on the wrong
Speaker 1: things.
Speaker 1: So so the so the main message of this talk
Speaker 1: that I wanted to deliver has to do with the
Speaker 1: simplicity of how one can do this.
Speaker 1: If you let.
Speaker 1: In the simplicity that I'm sharing with you,
Speaker 1: it can change your life.
Speaker 1: All you have to do is, from the perspective
Speaker 1: of being, is to realize and let go, and
Speaker 1: then, from the perspective of becoming, is
Speaker 1: to realize and respond.
Speaker 1: And if you do it because when you, if you
Speaker 1: do it, everything becomes clear for you.
Speaker 1: Because when you let go, your mind becomes
Speaker 1: clear your soul is invigorated.
Speaker 1: You're not a victim anymore.
Speaker 1: You win your independence, your sovereignty,
Speaker 1: you become a sovereign soul, you become
Speaker 1: wise, all as a result of letting go.
Speaker 1: That's all it takes.
Speaker 1: Just that one act can enlighten your whole
Speaker 1: being.
Speaker 1: You don't have to read a lot of books for
Speaker 1: that to happen.
Speaker 1: You don't have to read any In order to
Speaker 1: become a powerful player and a co-creator
Speaker 1: of the process.
Speaker 1: You have to learn how to have the courage
Speaker 1: to realize and respond and eventually learn
Speaker 1: how to respond in a way that moves faster
Speaker 1: than thought.
Speaker 1: When we respond, when we awaken to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse and we respond to it,
Speaker 1: it's a response that moves faster than
Speaker 1: thought, faster than the mind can think.
Speaker 1: That means you're responding from the
Speaker 1: source of evolutionary intelligence.
Speaker 1: That means you'll bear witness to yourself
Speaker 1: acting.
Speaker 1: You won't even know where it's coming from
Speaker 1: it will feel so right.
Speaker 1: And when this happens again and again and
Speaker 1: again and again, you start to feel like a
Speaker 1: master improviser playing the game of life
Speaker 1: and it's contributing in ways that are very
Speaker 1: important.
Speaker 1: And in this teaching, ideally, the goal is
Speaker 1: to do this together with other people.
Speaker 1: So it's not just you by yourself, but when
Speaker 1: you get a group of people that are
Speaker 1: practicing so diligently and so much
Speaker 1: commitment, it starts to create waves.
Speaker 1: So in the path as a whole, I believe to
Speaker 1: repeat what I said earlier needs to include
Speaker 1: the path of sudden awakening and the path
Speaker 1: of gradual awakening.
Speaker 1: Both need to be embraced.
Speaker 1: Now, wake up suddenly and practice
Speaker 1: diligently with all of your heart.
Speaker 1: There's always farther to go, so much more
Speaker 1: to become, so much more to understand and
Speaker 1: so much more to create.
Speaker 1: The ego's reluctance is always in I don't
Speaker 1: wanna let go.
Speaker 1: The ego's always reluctant.
Speaker 1: The ego's, if you just check it out, say
Speaker 1: what's in the way?
Speaker 1: The egoic reluctance to what?
Speaker 1: To letting go and to responding.
Speaker 1: You say but you didn't let go, why not?
Speaker 1: You say, I don't know.
Speaker 1: So if you pay attention, you see, the only
Speaker 1: thing in our way, in one's way, in your way,
Speaker 1: is the reluctance of the ego to either let
Speaker 1: go or to respond.
Speaker 1: It's important in life, when important
Speaker 1: things happen, that we respond and that
Speaker 1: we're ready to respond without hesitation.
Speaker 1: Preach from the egoic reluctance.
Speaker 1: Why didn't you respond?
Speaker 1: I don't know.
Speaker 1: I just always felt very reluctant.
Speaker 1: Why I don't know?
Speaker 1: I don't know.
Speaker 1: I just always felt very reluctant.
Speaker 1: Why, I don't know.
Speaker 1: But you wanted this, yeah, I know.
Speaker 1: So if we wanna be free, letting go must be
Speaker 1: free from reluctance ultimately, and our
Speaker 1: ability and willingness to respond has to
Speaker 1: be free from reluctance ultimately, and our
Speaker 1: be free from reluctance.
Speaker 1: Then we're well on our way.
Speaker 1: Then you're living an extraordinary life
Speaker 1: for extraordinary reasons that'll have
Speaker 1: extraordinary consequences.
Speaker 1: That's the kind of life I wanna live.
Speaker 1: I imagine it's the kind of life you wanna
Speaker 1: live too Living an extraordinary life for
Speaker 1: extraordinary reasons.
Speaker 1: It has extraordinary consequences, and
Speaker 1: check it out.
Speaker 1: You can do this every day.
Speaker 1: You can practice letting go right after you
Speaker 1: get up in the morning and you sit down to
Speaker 1: meditate.
Speaker 1: If that's what you do whenever you do it,
Speaker 1: you can practice letting go every day.
Speaker 1: I always like to say God gives us yet
Speaker 1: another chance to let go unconditionally,
Speaker 1: of absolutely everything.
Speaker 1: How generous is she?
Speaker 1: You mean, I get another chance to let go of
Speaker 1: absolutely everything.
Speaker 1: Yes, are you going to do it this time?
Speaker 1: Are you going to do it this time?
Speaker 1: Yes, so we get a chance every day time.
Speaker 1: Yes, so we get a chance every day to
Speaker 1: practice letting go unconditionally of
Speaker 1: everything.
Speaker 1: We're so fortunate and we also get an
Speaker 1: opportunity every day to respond
Speaker 1: wholeheartedly and passionately and
Speaker 1: intelligently to life.
Speaker 1: How profound is your response to the life
Speaker 1: that you're living?
Speaker 1: Five how profound is your response to the
Speaker 1: life that you're living?
Speaker 1: If your response to the life that you're
Speaker 1: living is profound, your life will be an
Speaker 1: expression of awakened intelligence and
Speaker 1: awakened spiritual passion and care.
Speaker 1: The lives of saints and sages and great
Speaker 1: realizers are expressions of exactly that.
Speaker 1: No, why don't we try and be like that, live
Speaker 1: like that?
Speaker 1: I mean, I know life is hard.
Speaker 1: You know like being human is hard, but we
Speaker 1: have an enormous opportunity here that
Speaker 1: we've been given.
Speaker 1: So why not do whatever we've got to do to
Speaker 1: make the very best out of it?
Speaker 1: Why not do everything we need to do to make
Speaker 1: the very best out of it?
Speaker 1: I can't imagine there could be anything
Speaker 1: more important to do.
Speaker 1: Why would anything less than that be make
Speaker 1: any sense?
Speaker 1: So everything that I'm to repeat,
Speaker 1: everything that I'm sharing with you, you
Speaker 1: can do immediately, you can realize and let
Speaker 1: go tomorrow, and you can realize and
Speaker 1: respond.
Speaker 1: I'm saying tomorrow because where I am it's
Speaker 1: evening time, but if it's the early morning
Speaker 1: where you are, or the middle of the day,
Speaker 1: even better.
Speaker 1: No need to wait till tomorrow morning.
Speaker 1: So I think we should be grateful, we should
Speaker 1: learn to be grateful for the infinite
Speaker 1: opportunity.
Speaker 1: We have to do this Because as long as we're
Speaker 1: breathing, as long as breath is going in
Speaker 1: and out of our lungs, we're not in too much
Speaker 1: pain.
Speaker 1: We can realize and let go in every moment.
Speaker 1: And in the same way, as long as we're
Speaker 1: breathing in and not in too much pain, we
Speaker 1: can realize and respond with all of our
Speaker 1: hearts.
Speaker 1: Respond with all of our hearts and you're
Speaker 1: living a full life.
Speaker 1: Thank you.